what's going on guys so I did make my
review of the feature film that I made
when I was about 16 or 17 years old
which was my gift to you guys my way of
saying thank you for reaching 1 million
subscribers but I also just wanted to
make a dedicated video in which I could
just tell you guys how personally
thankful I am for sticking with me over
the past eight years when I started in
2009 it was purely for fun I honestly
didn't really know anything about
YouTube I didn't really understand the
rules
I knew that subscribers were good and
then if you had more that's a good thing
and that if people were watching your
videos that's a good thing but I had no
idea how monetization worked I didn't
understand really anything about the
technical side of YouTube or not really
how to make videos either like a lot of
my earlier videos were very poorly shot
with just one overhead light on my
ceiling no external microphone I had no
idea what color correction was and it's
a miracle that so many of you have stuck
with me for the past eight years and I
just wanted to say genuinely from the
bottom of my heart thank you all the way
back from my first Dragonball Evolution
video that I did that kind of exploded
and got me a lot of subscribers I have
been involved in some of the coolest
projects of my life and I've been able
to meet some of the coolest people that
I've ever met and had the true honor to
collaborate with so many amazing content
creators out there people like the
schmoes know my buddies Christian and
Mark and everyone else at that studio my
buddy josh mokuba who let me crash at
his place when I visited LA Jeremy
John's getting to meet and work with him
has been really amazing all the cool
people over at screen junkies that was a
total privilege to work with them as
well meeting Andre Meadows was awesome
and I got to do some videos with him my
good buddy Jake Baldino who now is like
this epic game ranks king of video games
guy Eric Strickler and all the guys that
pretty much it Adam from YMS
of course my good buddy John Flickinger
and Matt Brando getting to work with
them has been so much fun and the fine
folks over at channel awesome getting to
meet and work with Doug Walker was truly
a dream come true because nostalgia
critic was one of my very first
inspirations and going back to the
beginning my buddy Blake who ran a
YouTube channel at the time doing movie
reviews who inspired me to create my own
I'm still friends with him
Tom shadow bash he also still makes
youtube videos so many people that I've
been able to become close to and the
pals with and and just it's crazy it's
nuts when I sit down and think about the
past eight years but beyond all of that
the most important thing that I have
been able to do is connect with you guys
Star Wars Celebration was a humongously
i opening experience I met so many of
you and had the true honor to talk with
you guys and hear so many stories and
just go back and forth about film and
creating and filmmaking and how we just
inspire each other back and forth and my
experience that convention honestly
brought some tears to my eyes because I
had never really understood that it was
like a two-way thing it wasn't just that
I was creating videos for you guys you
guys were intern inspiring me back do
you remember the music video my older
subscribers will remember a music video
that we all made together it was to
promote ethnic diversity through music
and a lot of you guys who are very
talented submitted footage of you guys
dancing or playing musical instruments
and we all made a music video together
like the stuff that we've been able to
do over the years has for myself been so
much bigger than just talking about film
I've truly found a life course because
of you guys I went through a really
confusing period for the first few years
of my time here on YouTube where I
wasn't exactly sure what I wanted to do
with my life and because of you guys
I've been able to have a path that that
makes sense to me that I can see
genuinely you guys changed my life
I know that when I first started my
channel I had pretty much zero self
confidence and I'm pretty sure I
wouldn't have asked out my wife on our
first date if I hadn't have developed a
little bit of confidence in myself as a
person and a lot of that is because of
my youtube channel and now I'm married
to a wonderful beautiful woman I have so
much to thank you guys for and there's
really no words that I can choose to
describe it beyond just saying thank you
so much for continuing to enjoy the
content and also for giving me creative
freedom a lot of the reason that I love
making movie reviews is because I can
also include creative things in the
reviews like our Halloween specials we
do every year we've put a lot of work
and effort into those and a lot of
thought and planning and it's more than
just talking about scary movies it's
being creative is it's sharing an art
form with you or like the skit I did for
my Jason Bourne review or the lego stuff
I did for Star Wars things like that are
the reason why I have so much fun
talking about film because I know that
you guys don't just want me to sit here
and wave my hands around and go this
movie suck this movie was good you
actually enjoy the content the creative
side of making videos and so many of you
make really impressive videos too I've
gotten a lot of short films sent to me
in my p.o box a lot of them have really
impressed me and I'm honored to be able
to discuss film with people who actually
appreciate it and who enjoy the creative
side also I've been able to make a lot
of short films on the side that I've
never published on YouTube because of
you guys you guys have allowed me to
save money to create budgets to work
with really talented people here in Ohio
and make films on my own to hopefully
show at film festivals I have a film
right now that we've been working on
it's in post-production I'll tell you
guys more info about that soon when I
have an actual premiere date that I can
share with you but we're really excited
about that too and that's another thing
that I could not have done without you
guys I owe you so much thanks and I just
want to say thank you for the past eight
years for sticking with me
for enjoying the content and for just
being awesome I couldn't be more
grateful because the way I've always
viewed myself from the beginning the way
I still be myself no matter what you may
think of me like if you love my videos
or if you hate my videos I am just a guy
in Ohio who really likes movies and I
have the privilege of being able to talk
about my opinions on films with you guys
and even if I had a hundred subs I'd
probably still be doing this because as
I said when I started this channel I had
no idea how YouTube worked and I was
still making videos while having a
normal full-time job so it's never
really been a question for me this is
just what I love doing and it's become
something far bigger than I could have
possibly ever imagined and I'm really
happy about that but even if it was just
like a hundred subs and I was still
talking about movies and making the same
content I would still be having a blast
and I just want to thank you guys thank
you so much for continuing to watch I
have a lot more plan for the future
we're doing a lot of really cool stuff
later this year and I've even done some
collaborations with other youtubers that
have an aired yet that will air soon
that I didn't want to mention because I
don't want to spoil it but it's going to
be exciting and I'm just really I'm just
happy thank you guys you are the best if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes
[Music]